hello linkedin we are back
live this week i'm joined
by lewis who works for darwin
recruitment
and uh really excited to to have uh
lewis here for
30 minutes or so if you didn't see the
episode released this week lewis joined
me on the recruitment mentors podcast
so we're going to chat for the next 30
minutes have a bit of an honest
open conversation dig into sort of the
now
what challenges lewis is facing right
now how he's overcoming them
what he's hearing from his teams and
lewis a lot of his role
is focused on business development so
we're definitely going to dig into that
but for those of um for those people
that may not know you louis
and your background if you if we could
start there and then
we'll dig into it yeah sure thanks again
for having me hey jim
um so brief intro into myself i've been
doing recruitment for for 10 years
uh the last seven of those years have
been spent at darwin recruitment where i
started as a trainee kind of working my
way up the ranks um
working in denmark now in america and i
currently sit as the director of
business development so
my role for the most part is centered
around
initiating uh relationships with built
with businesses um starting to build on
those relationships and then
predominantly introducing someone from
the team who would then start to nurture
and you know expand those relationships
over time
okay that's good to know so and that's
remained
and that's remained the case um
during the whole overview period like
you haven't then got back
sourcing candidates is has it still
remained like business development yeah
just for context for people and for me
yeah so i'm still sourcing so there is
an element of my role that that
requires me to find candidates for two
reasons really one
because you you have to stay close to
the candidate market
to be able to stay on top of leads like
doing candidate development
is part of doing business development in
my opinion um
first and foremost you never know when
those candidates are going to be hiring
managers so it's good to build
relationships early thinking long term
always um and then secondly
i'm more than happy to pick up 100 of
the 360 deal
if i find a candidate myself on occasion
now for the most part i'm passing those
relationships over
but if i know a candidate or have
someone in my network i'm going to find
them get them in process place them
and and pick up the commission okay
correct i'll just add them
and then find a bit of context yeah you
live in
massachusetts well yes and no i moved
um five six weeks ago now to new
hampshire
so i'm an hour away from mass um a
couple of reasons again being
first one is the tax-free state so um
basically promoted myself
and then secondly i'm i'm growing a
family so uh
whilst covert is going on it's it's a
much less densely populated area and uh
you just you know you're not on top of
people i much prefer that one
my wife's pregnant fair enough and then
you recruit in the tech sector
and in terms of the businesses that you
support is it typically limited to the
state that you live in or just find a
bit of context on that in terms of
typical states or where businesses
typically are based where you support
yeah so the way the business is set up
is that we have
consultants looking after each technical
vertical um
in the us we have a little bit more
freedom and flexibility in terms of
what we um what we look after or who we
support
and we're not tied geographically to a
specific state in america so
for the most part a lot of our business
is done in new york boston
chicago and uh and california san
francisco
um although we do have some some other
opportunities going on down in the kind
of florida and atlanta areas
okay interesting right so let's get into
this there's a couple of questions that
have come through already but
everyone that's joining us thank you we
will get your questions answered
so for me i think the daily
conversations that i have
covid no kovid business development
typically is the area that people want
to develop most in
um so let's talk about that for a second
like what has been your biggest
challenge
over during covid on the business
development side would you say that
you've come up against a lot
and you've had had to work really hard
to overcome would you say
well i would say that obviously it's
been challenging for everybody but we
pivoted quite quickly
um it's very obvious that you're not
going to do much business with a travel
company right now
but you are likely to do more business
with a you know a company trying to
produce vaccines or pharmaceutical drugs
or someone who's
heavily involved in the ecommerce world
because people are still spending money
although they're you know being laid off
left right and we've got thanksgiving
coming up christmas coming up people are
still
buying um so it was more a case of
pivoting initially
trying to just see where the demand was
but i will say that
we at least i focus predominantly on
data science and people haven't stopped
looking for high-level data scientists
although the market has been flooded
with with candidates potential
candidates
that hasn't changed the fact that all
the good guys and girls are still
happily employed so there is still a
huge demand for
for senior level talent in in this
particular space which
just means that we haven't been really
that affected during covert okay fair
that's fair that's good yeah
yeah so so i guess number one challenge
then that i've heard
numerous times which i'm sure you've
heard which is in line with what you
just said
louis why would i pay you a recruitment
fee
when we can we can source this directly
what are you saying to that um
more often than not the reason they're
having that conversation with me is
because they can't
so i think where we focus specifically
on data science and kind of like
surrounding technologies we do a bit of
product as well we've got a new employee
that just joined us
um there's always going to be demand
it's not easy to find these people so as
long as you're
taking time to research businesses
understanding their need before going in
and and kind of trying to sell them
something if you're bringing value to
them
you typically don't have to sell why you
would work with me
you know the candidate does that for you
um
i feel like if you have good product
people are always going to want to
buy from you so staying on top of the
market
staying on top of the trends really just
identifying where the needs are
some obvious places for me right now at
least where i see machine learning data
science going is automation
and then certainly crypto is is a is a
hot topic right now
um with digital currencies and security
and everything surrounding that so
i think if you just if you just are
aware of where the tech market's going
you really shouldn't have to sell your
service too much if you have a good
product
okay so let's dig into this then this
question has come through and this is
what
i i guess i'm most interested in my
question when i prepared for this was
okay great get that but like what has
been or can what has continued to be in
the most effective way
for lewis to generate business and pick
up business
so this question has pretty much come
from richard james
how have you adapted your approach if
you have adapted your approach you're
talking about about well
you need to make sure you're on top of
the market and if you've continued to do
that
you understand what problems you can
solve by
making sure you're still getting the
right talent or talent that you know can
solve problems for your businesses then
you should still there should still be
plenty of opportunities but like what's
been the most effective way
of you winning a business or continuing
to and also
have you adapted your approach in any
way yeah
thanks for the question firstly richard
and to answer that
i wouldn't say that i'm you know pushing
the boundaries too far but i i actually
have a podcast that i run myself
and i leverage that in many different
ways first and foremost for me to to
gain a better understanding of the space
secondly so i have some relevant topics
that i can go back to the
the the industry and talk about um and
then thirdly
a lot of the people that i bring onto my
podcast are hiring managers
um i might not be supporting them in the
short term
i've always got a longer term view when
i when i do recruitment
um so i'm not necessarily picking up the
phone and trying to push candidates down
people's necks i'm just trying to create
those initial relationships
and and leveraging my podcast to do that
um
and then creating some exclusivity
around it and and bringing some value to
them after so
for example i have a group on linkedin
which is full of the speakers that i've
had on my podcast and they all
chat with each other so now i've got a
group of hiring managers that i've
brought value to
and occasionally i'll ask them for help
on something whether that be introducing
me to someone else
whether that be what's the opinion on
this candidate whether that be has
anyone got any jobs
um and it's been quite effective so
just thinking outside of the the kind of
just pick up the phone or send an email
box like what other tools do you have
that you can use and leverage
and also like what other social media
platforms can you use
um if you are working in certain
industries
linkedin might not be the best place to
to to
to source or do business development for
example if you if you work in the
security space twitter is a fantastic
place to be
so just just being aware of what you've
got available to you
has helped with not only keeping it
fresh as well because after 10 years of
picking up the phone
you kind of want to try new things and
this podcast has been
really exciting for me and and it's
generally
started uh
it wouldn't far off be almost 12 months
to
to the week okay also so it's pretty
good i i
obviously you know you know what i do
and i i think podcast is a great
uh it's a lot if if a recruit was to ask
me
right if i was to do one if i was to
choose and give every everything
to one marketing channel or one
marketing activity
what would it be it would be starting a
podcast for sure
because of the reason that you're
talking about so for anyone joining us
today who are thinking
how the hell do i start that because i'm
sure you had these worries or whatever
right
so what if i'm thinking now right you
know what that's that's a great
thing for me to do what would be your
like i don't know one two three bits of
advice
that you'd you tell me so i can actually
kick start this
and maybe share what you did to get this
started instead of being paralyzed
by i don't know what to do yeah
definitely i think
um be authentic like
most recruiters aren't experts although
we proclaim to be them
we we don't know the depth of of what
we're selling
certainly in the technology world if i
did i'd probably go and be at that
scientist they earned a ton of money
um but generally speaking like stick
within your wheelhouse
so for me the the mindset behind my
podcast is i bring hr knowledge
or recruitment knowledge and then
combine it with technical experts and we
talk about recruiting processes
or hiring processes um or just career
general kind of processes and and and
that's really worked for me
i tried to do a couple of deep technical
dives and i just look like an idiot
so i just haven't done them again
well they were the first one or two i
did and they were actually in person so
it was even more embarrassing
like i could wear grey now quite
confidently and not worry about sweating
but back back then it was really
difficult really difficult
and um i just changed it up and stuck
with what i knew and it made it a lot
easier
as soon as you have like one bad
conversation or one bad podcast then you
do a second one it could be quite
discouraging
um and and it's hard then to go on to a
third or fourth or fifth so just stick
with what you know that's my first bit
of advice
second piece of advice is um
i guess just just have a plan have a
goal like what are you trying to achieve
from your podcast is let's not shy away
from the fact that it's a business
development
tool it really is and and and you should
make sure that you're leveraging it to
create business don't just do it and
then become a podcaster like
that that's fine if you want to go down
that route but your your boss isn't
going to be happy if you're just
creating content and not money
so you have to have some end goal to it
um
and uh and then there's there's a fine
balance between doing it too often
and not doing it enough and i think i'm
leaning on the side of doing it too
often
because it starts to have a negative
effect once a week
once a week um and sometimes twice a
week and uh
and then i i post a lot of content like
my own content
i don't do as much resharing of content
but i feel like it's starting to have
adverse effects now on linkedin so i've
i still haven't figured it out
but sticking with what i know made me a
lot more confident in having these
conversations
and then just ensuring that you're
bringing value to the speaker
because the speaker will give you time
but if you don't bring in value and
don't follow up with them
after then you've just had a chat with
someone that was recorded once and no
one remembers it
and you do that by you've got you're
connecting them with other experts
that they could learn yeah yeah yeah
yeah so nice so
okay final thing on this i've definitely
got just one piece of advice that i've
given that has helped people in this but
the people that are joining us and go in
okay that that sounds great
but like how does like let's just be
really practical here like
how has this helped you biz on business
development
like how was that how has that then
actually helped you like has it
enabled you to pick up the phone or
reach out wherever you've done it
and you've got more yeses you've got
more of an opportunity to start building
a relationship like how has it actually
helped you
i think i think the latter really is
that it's created an opportunity
for me to have a conversation with
someone that might not already normally
pick up the phone
um so i've kind of got over that first
hurdle
i think there is no gatekeeper in
in the sense of introducing a podcast or
hire manager because
the gatekeeper's not going to go we're
not interested in working recruiters
well i'm not
i'm not selling recruitment services so
you've already kind of crossed that
hurdle you're already
in in the door so to speak um and again
if you brought value to them and you've
introduced them to people
after and you see them communicating
like
i don't want to say they owe you because
that's not the right way of putting it
but
there is an element of right okay cool
he brought value to me so is there an
opportunity for me to help him
and i've seen that that's how that's how
we operate isn't it like if you help me
yeah i'm
naturally inspired by that
yeah yeah exactly okay exactly and and
they're just way more open to
to doing that um whether again whether
that be
next week or in two years from now i
guess time to tell but
it just definitely created that that
opportunity that open door
i think just really quick i just want to
have my two pence in there just because
it's something i can add value in
so what i so when you're talking about
the strategy piece so if you were to sit
down with me lewis when you
when you if you if we had if we sat down
together before you started this podcast
and you're like right here i've got this
idea i think this really helped a
business development blah blah
this is what i would have said to you so
you're completely right
one of the main reasons why you'd stop
or you louis wouldn't be sharing
um podcast episodes 90 days from that
initial sit down
would be because it hasn't generated
results quickly or it hasn't you haven't
seen the sort of direct correlation
with how does this help me as a
recruiter and that could come from you
yourself or it could come from your boss
or whatever right
so for me if you're watching this you're
like right you know what i am going to
take action on a podcast
then what you need to do is map out your
dream 30 guests
your first dream 30 podcast guess first
10
existing clients number one reason
because
it's a great relationship building
exercise also
you're comfortable with these people i'd
like to think you're comfortable with
them so you have more of a chance of
having a decent conversation
if you know each other and then thirdly
it can become a great
digital asset that you can utilize when
headhunting and recruiting for their
teams
the second ten are then target clients
who are your target clients you should
know who those are and then
like lewis has been doing pro actually
reach out to these people
and talk to them about your podcast the
third ten
and to make this a thirty and then ten
fault leaders hate that phrase but 10
people that already have a brand in your
space
and what you're then doing is piggy and
back off piggying back off their brand
and that can accelerate the viewership
accelerate the listens etc etc
so the reason why i give people that
advice is if you
make it from day one like intertwined
with your recruitment desk
existing clients target clients these
things then you're gonna have a much
better chance of continuing it
so that's what i would have said to you
lewis in terms of a lot of strategy and
then that hopefully would have given you
the best possible chance of continuing
with it um yeah
yeah definitely love that so i've got a
couple of questions so
i definitely so if you're still with us
i'm definitely going to get lewis's take
on his thoughts and what he sees in like
the u.s
market landscape i've got a question
where someone wants your opinion
lewis on like the difference between uk
us but let me
i've got a question here from nathan
that i didn't want to forget
everyone loves this question what is the
structure
of your day everyone wants to know what
people's structures are
right so you could yeah like tell us a
bit about what's like what are the
non-negotiables in in your days or
or weeks um lewis what does your what
does a typical day
for lewis look like which you always aim
to achieve because
that gets you closer to your goals yeah
so
leveraging the podcast again that that
creates the structure for me and then i
work around that so
every thursday 11 i go live with a guest
again i might be adjusting that soon but
that then means that on monday
i have to follow up with that guest i
have to create an event page i have to
start
pushing that out to people having
conversations with people about about
the show and then
trying to have conversations about
whether they'd want to come on it after
um one of the things that i do which i i
don't know if
lots of people do it it's a bit of a i
wouldn't say it's a secret source but
at the start of every week and the end
of every week i look at investments
that have been made and that was one of
the things that helped me get through
covid
so there's a number of different
platforms that you can use that actively
follow
large investments being made into tech
companies right go to
give us give us some website so you look
at go to one that you'd recommend just
be sure that's cool
yeah so index is is it's index
and that then shows a list of businesses
that
first and foremost you know i've got
cash because it tells you how much
they've got
and i try and then target the ones who
aren't quite established enough
to have that really um built out
recruitment team internet because again
i think we talked about this on the pod
that
that's quite common out here for a lot
of businesses to have internal
recruiting businesses
um and then i reach out and and
i talk about their investment i try and
figure out where they're going to be
putting that money how much of that's
going to be put into tech and research
and development
um and then i started to create my my
you know business opportunity from there
um whether that be introducing
candidates i've got other people in my
team that might be
valuable to them in terms of their
growth um
and then there's not a lot more to it
than that it's all about like
following up with those businesses
following up with those potential
speakers
finding good candidates i mean obviously
if we've got a good candidate in process
we'll take that candidate to market and
build a project plan around them you
know identifying businesses that are
similar to the ones he's interviewing it
now or
she's interviewing it now and their
interests and stuff so
there isn't too much more to it than
that um i start my day
8 o'clock 8 30 finish 6 30 7 o'clock
most days
um i'm i used to be i don't want to say
really bad at it but i used to
never there was never an end to my
working week so i work saturday and
sundays and i've kind of decided that
i'm i've taken those back so make sure
that you make time for yourself to stay
fit to stay healthy to eat
to to just you know have a personal life
recruitment
a lot of people are successful in
recruitment when it's that's all they do
but you do need to find a balance um
so my job is monday to friday unless it
absolutely requires me to work on the
weekend
and it and it has to be a damn good
reason for that um
otherwise it's you know just helps me
enjoy what i'm doing and keeps me fresh
yeah i like it let's dig into the u.s
market
so background so i've got this question
just while
we're talking about this let me just get
it up for you
ollie thompson how much more of an
opportunity is it in the u.s for
tech ds recruitment compared to ldn
london industry-wise related to
financial services i did also know that
may not be your world but
i'm sure you can give some context here
but obviously background
you started your career at darwin
particularly did you ever recruit in the
uk or did you straight
was it straight away in it's not a
darwin
not a doll and that was um i mean that
was right the beginning of my career so
i couldn't really compare the two
and i really didn't know a huge amount
about recruitment or the market at the
time and data science really wasn't even
on yeah it was lips i mean why didn't
why didn't you compare
because you used to recruit stockholm
right
i would say just generally speaking like
technology is more advanced
in america they are the early adopters
of tech
you see most of the advancements happen
here first followed by london
and then other areas in europe germany
is another good place for that denmark
are late adopters
so there's there's a big time delay
between when something innovative
happens here
and then you start to see that happening
in denmark um
yeah so i don't know enough about london
in that sense i just know that america
are
way more advanced and because of that
there's always a lot of excitement
around technology and there's always
that demand because there's always
something new
um and then how does that translate
no no that's i appreciate it but then
how does that translate
i know we spoke about this on the
podless but just for context for people
like we like i've had a number of people
in the podcast that have said
uh fees are typically bigger in in
america let's just talk about that for
context
not because yeah that's what i just talk
about but i think people want to know
that right so
if i am recruiting right now in the uk
market and i'm typically recruiting this
particular type of skill set
for this industry what if i then try and
build the desk in america
does that mean i can potentially have
more money
definitely yeah it's it's not
it's it's not wild to think that you can
secure
25 30 terms with these finance
organizations for these
data scientists at least again from from
my experience yeah your context yeah
yeah from my perspective and the average
data scientist earns anything from
150 to 200k that's the average data
scientist yeah
um once you start getting into four or
five years of experience if they're a us
citizen you know they've got very
specific skills
in machine learning programming they can
be anywhere upwards of
250 3 400 k and then when you start
putting a 25 or 30
feet on top of that you really can't
compare the fees in america
to anywhere else in the world yeah um i
think
you should be able to quite easily see
the comparison right i'd like to think
surely you could go on job boards and
stuff and be and search for the typical
job titles that
you help then i don't know could you do
that i guess
yeah you could i'm sure you could i
think that's that's
one way of looking at it the only thing
is is that i don't necessarily think job
boards dictate what the
the salaries are in the market because
in data science they're so indiv they're
so individual
and if one person's a data scientist at
a
again let's just say a travel company
and one person is a data scientist at a
quant fund
there could be 200k difference in their
ote
i can't be that big same level of
experience um
somewhat of similar skills but that
there's such a difference
industry to industry so a lot of those
businesses aren't always advertising
either so so although you can look on a
job board it's not necessarily going to
give you a really clear understanding
yeah yeah it's not it's not realistic
and when businesses
look at job boards and say well this is
what the market's paying it's not
that's not what they pay every single
business is is different
yeah so i guess for those of you that
are with us i i've had
a number of people that have taken their
recruitment career to america
i would say from the people that i've
spoken to and it has been a variety of
sectors from tech to engineering
manufacturing
like main we don't know we can't just
save for every sector right but
i'd say most of the time recruiters have
said
typically they would typically they've
been able to secure 25 30
terms and typically the the
um salary bandings have been typically
on average high in america
so like if you're with us and you've
identified there's a potential market
for in america
then mainly i've heard that
generally you can potentially own bigger
fees now it doesn't mean that it's still
not hard work
but i think a lot of people interested
aren't they like can i actually
make more money in america or are the
fees bigger and i'd say from the
conversations that i've had
most of the time i'll probably answer
that question yes and obviously
you're testing into that as well and
you've seen that but we can't obviously
say for every
every sector company it's not the same
for every sector i think
the one thing you just need to keep in
mind is that when you get here
you will come up against internal
recruiters
and they're an integral part of the
process and you can't get around them so
whilst you can earn a lot more money
and there's not some immediate
competition externally you will be met
with internal competition
all the time so it it's not easy
yeah typically what they're called yeah
yep yeah
okay so let's as we finish then
if you're still with us and you you want
to get your question answered
and put it in the comments but
what's lewis's perspective so i think
i mentioned this on the last lie with
oliver cook from faded international
like
before covid i would say a lot of
recruitment business owners who are
serious about growth
have like mentioned about taking their
business to america
like a lot of uk based recruitment
businesses that came up in a lot of
conversations
right so you've been there for a while
now
and you you work really hard to get
yourself to the point where you've moved
over there and these things
but i guess what's lewis's perspective
and just from what you can see on like
the landscape or potentially more
uk businesses or uk recruiters taking
their
career to america like how how realistic
is that how is that going to evolve and
take shape going into 2021 do you think
i think it's
very realistic to see more uk presence
in america
for the most part a lot of the
successful recruitment companies here
are english or uk based originally
um again i think that's just because
there's such a
an attractive career path internally
for people out here in america i would
say that the key to success and i think
this is going to be
we're going to be a testament to that as
we continue to grow
is hiring remotely around america
so there's loads of really talented 360
recruiters
and often they're split between account
development and and delivery here
so to get the 360 people it's unlikely
you'll find them all in one place
so i think if you're a uk business
looking to come to america
really be open to the idea of having
hubs across the u.s
um you might not consistently find 100
people in boston
for example we've just hired someone a
little bit further south
um who's gonna be i think she might be
moving to denver or something soon
um but we've got a bunch of people that
we're looking at across the u.s
and um the talent pool has just opened
up completely and uh and
maybe that wouldn't have happened before
right it wouldn't have happened it just
wouldn't
we tried to hire in massachusetts and it
was not impossible
difficult yeah um just that's exciting
i guess really exciting i think
there's just you know we spent a year
and a half two years trying to get
applicants coming through the door and
we just we just couldn't and now we
opened up the doors so to speak to to
the rest of america
and we just have loads of good talent in
the pipeline um and you know as long as
the team keeps producing
it's going to be a pretty exciting 2021
for us i think as
as a as a team yeah so let's
wrap this up then lewis if it's okay
with you if like
if i'm watching this right now i mean
i'm i'm sort of thinking right long term
i'd love to be able to take to my my
recruitment career to the states
what would be your like three best tips
to me
if i'm like right so i've done a bit of
research
it seems like there's definitely an
opportunity for me to
take sort of what i've been doing in the
uk or europe markets to america
like there's a bit of context there and
i'm like you know what i'm really
serious about
taking my career to america
talking to lewis at the beginning of
your journey of doing this yeah
what what would you say to me three
first pieces of advice
the first step is a personal one so when
you get here
very quickly try to establish some form
of friendship group
whether that be going and joining a
sports club or a fitness center or
i know you could you could join a choir
whatever it might be that you're into
um i don't know um
but but create a friendship group
because it can be incredibly lonely
moving to a a different country and not
having
a support group around you your business
is there to support you but when
the lights shut off and the office is
closed you're on your own
so make a conscious effort to get to
know people
to build those relationships externally
um second respect the the recruiting
process
i think naturally everyone's taught in
european markets to
go around recruitment teams and work
directly with hiring managers whilst
you'll
see a lot of opportunity doing that
you'll get shut down a lot
and you'll lose potential business
businesses and clients if you don't
include recruiters
in the process they can be in a really
helpful part of the process
if you build that relationship right to
start with
um yeah respect the process
um and thirdly just have fun like
i think what's the worst that can happen
right you it doesn't work out and you go
home
um but you can leverage that to motivate
you in that if you're really enjoying
yourself
if you decide to put your feet up for a
little while or you don't focus
you go home so so see that as a positive
and uh and a motivational tool um
i'm sure your mum will or your mum or
dad will have a room available and a bed
made for you if it doesn't work
definitely yeah yeah and i think just
for context there's nobody spoke about
this on the podcast so feel free to add
anything on this
and then we'll leave it here but like
it's a great advice then i think
final bits of context was like you you
you had a goal of billings and certain
things that you
really worked hard to achieve before you
even thought about
getting on a plane can you so like
why don't we just talk a bit about just
really quick if it's okay with you like
just
time frames and a bit about that because
i think that would be really good final
context for people because they might be
like
sounds good but how do i even get there
or like because i've heard
most not all the time but a lot of the
time people do start working american
hours in the uk
and try and build towards something
before they even think about getting on
the plane
so like if you don't mind just telling
us a bit about that and then we'll we'll
leave it there
yeah so we had a a obviously a desire as
a business to make sure that
we could afford moving to america um
i think initially there's a huge outlay
when it comes to getting your visas when
it comes to
relocating packages everything like that
and then there's a
period of time that a business needs to
anticipate that
in the first month or the first few
weeks at the very least
you're likely to to not see a lot of
production because people are out there
enjoying themselves experiencing the
the country the state whatever it is
that they've moved into um so so the
recruitment drops off
so there is an amount of money that
typically is is going to cover your
overheads and then obviously there wants
to be a bit of profit involved there so
we had set a figure which was a hundred
thousand dollars per month
um for our team consecutively for three
months that would then unlock the doors
to
us then relocating um for me personally
i think
initially we probably tried to reach too
far
you'll do less i can only talk from from
the perspective of data science and tech
but you'll do less deals initially
but there are much higher value so don't
be disappointed
if you only did six deals in one year
but if they're
all valued at 50 60k all of a sudden
you've got a very productive recruiter
but you just you just have to be
prepared that you might not have as many
processes going on
you have to be way more involved in the
processes than you do in europe
um and just don't be disheartened if you
don't see
an impact or a return straight away i
think
six yeah six to eight months is a fair
run rate um
so getting here getting exciting part of
the way starting to establish
relationships
starting to see progress and then
starting to make placements seems like a
long time if you say after six months
you might start making money
but when you do start making money that
they also are so large that
you'll forget about those those quiet
months yeah and then really quickly and
i'll let you go and then so that's
great and then and then how long was it
before you even
got on the plane because it was quite a
while wasn't it we did it we did a year
and a half
incubated in in the uk which was working
from
midday to one or two of the amount of
time that you know what i mean
18 months of graft american hours
late before you even thought about
the american birds digging the british
accent and all that
you know what i mean before you comment
over there you're putting in all that
work
yeah you have to you give up your
personal life completely yeah you have
to give up everything
you know you're on that friday when the
boys and girls are down to pub and
they're calling you like come and get
some shots here you can't
you're still working yeah
no i love that louis absolute pleasure
thank you so much for joining us on this
live hope
you all enjoyed that got value from it
if you didn't get your question answered
i know lewis is super keen to
help so draw from a message but thank
you so much everyone for joining us
and uh louis thanks for coming on
appreciate it
cheerson